- Regina, were you in the first one?
- Yeah.
(laughing)
- Regina was a stripper!
- [Regina] Did you hear
him? I was an exotic dancer.
- Taye is asking Regina if
she was in the first two.
Oh no, Okay.
No, stripper.
If I'm the side piece,
you're the stripper.
(laughing)
- I was with a heart of gold.
- [Regina] You were!
- [Nia] I had so much respect
for you on that first day.
- Take off your clothes
he'll recognize you.
(laughing)
- She was in shape, she was
in shape in that first one.
- Wait what does that mean?
- No no, she's in shape
now too but she has -
- [Kelly] No no no wait.
- She's in shape now too. No.
- [Nia] Hand the mic to Kelly.
- I gotta call Morris out
I'm gonna call Morris out.
- [Morris] what's that?
- Morris, did you not have
a body double at some point?
- Yeah well -
(ooh's from audience)
I did, I did.
- [Nia] I didn't know that!
- He did.
- Because what happened was,
so, the very first thing that
I'm in, you know I'm
naked supposedly you know,
and I'm used to seeing Taye naked -
- [Nia] That was the real
thing the ladies requested.
- Taye normally comes to
rehearsals naked by the way.
(laughing)
- [Regina] Just like that.
- There was a scene in the
show, not the first scene but
there's a scene at the pool
where I did have a double.
- Yes, yeah just because he was naked.
- [Nia] Wow.
- [Morris] He was really naked.
- [Nia] You're calling
regina out, I'm just saying.
- [Morris] No, I wasn't
calling her out no,
Regina's in shape and
we talked about this,
we has a whole press
junket where we went on
and on about how in shape regina is.
Trust me.
- She does not eat.
- [Kelly] Morris I'm
totally messing with you.
- Nah, its all good.
(laughing)